when I heard about goals in the past
it's like here is your Target and it was
always disappointing and confusing and
the reason why is when you set a goal
you're setting it at the furthest
distance away from that reality from day
one is the first distance you'll ever be
away from that goal so it means you
don't know anything about that reality
and every day as you get closer to that
goal it becomes clearer and it becomes
more real and oftentimes you change your
mind you're like oh wait this is not
what I actually want or you learn
something new it's actually over here so
I think that rather it being the Final
Destination it's like a lighthouse you
never go to the lighthouse right the
lighthouse stands at a place that's
actually really hazardous it's there to
make sure the chips don't go there but
ships can also use it to navigate you're
setting some destination for you to
learn and if you think about it as a
lighthouse then going off course or you
know changing course if you will is part
of it